I'm ready to hear this hitter hi-c uh
yeah this is a burning ban of native
Mississippi would play for Bishop
building we're in that Bishop burn ban
oh yeah
a surprise caller is impatient over here
anyway look we're talking about the dark
arts decision we're sitting the living
room and we're just wondering is the
bush making it come back come in
oh you mean George Bush for the record
when that time with the presidency we're
talking about vaginas and yeah oh okay
you talking about that that you don't
seem talking about that pheasant boy
from hairstyles revolving around that I
just don't see much of the whole
industry up or the triangle much more
seasoned it's either all gone or it's
all there if you I'm saying are you
talking about that full feel that you
talking about that you know that front
forty well it's funny you talk about
that you know like it's so funny because
his this is the drummer right now that
called and a bishop gun of the band and
they're asking is that but you know is
that thing making a comeback or what is
it yeah I don't know that you know I
don't mind I don't want that cornfield
down there I'll use terms since I used
to work on his father's farm I don't
want them you know I don't want them
stalks you know I don't want that field
of dreams down there bright where you
came even you know saying you might lose
if you bring a friend you might lose
them down there or you might lose your
freakin you know a piece of jewelry I
don't want that you know but I wouldn't
mind something a little low-grade you
know maybe some soybean you know maybe
something as high as corn but you know
me not corn with cotton maybe some Milo
you know wheat I'll go with that Streamy
wheat down there bruh you know a little
bit of cream of wheat you know get a
serving going I'll do something like
that but I don't know is the bush making
a comeback how's it going that's a
goodness that's tough question maybe
some ladies if there's some ladies out
there who listen can you let us know is
that Bush gonna make a comeback you know
I was just talking to a black friend of
mine about the jheri curl hair cut where
the [__] is that thing you know a lot of
men out there a lot of a lot of a lot of
african-american and black men out there
saying they got that swagger they braved
they this day that but ain't nobody
ready to rock that J curl out there
where's that it you know I'm saying
grease
and grease out baby let's see it all
because y'all want to see that hang time
coming off the back you ain't got the
balls to grow the falls baby and you
know that so let's see it man I wouldn't
mind seeing that I would let's see it
all let's see it all man thank you guys
for checking out this clip and if you
want to see another clip then you can
look at this clip or this clip either
one of these so did you pick one or he's
still just watching me do this cuz this
is alarming